paraíso fiscal para algunos y éxitos
económicos para otros lo cierto es que
panamá un enclave vital para el comercio
mundial que ha registrado en los últimos
15 años uno de los mayores crecimientos
económicos del mundo es un país está de
moda
hoy buscamos conocerlo un poco mejor
panamá es una franja de tierra de 75 mil
kilómetros cuadrados bañada por el mar
caribe y el océano pacífico tiene como
países vecinos a costa rica y colombia
con una población ligeramente superior a
los 3 millones y medio de personas y un
pib per cápita varía de positivo de casi
20 mil euros
su economía está centrada
fundamentalmente en el sector servicios
explorar el colonizado por los españoles
en el siglo 16 tras la la independencia
de las colonias americanas panamá unió
su suerte a la de colombia y no fue
hasta 1903 cuando finalmente obtuvo su
independencia proceso en el que contó
con la inestimable ayuda de los eeuu que
tenían como objetivo construir y
gestionar bajo su soberanía el que sin
duda el elemento más famoso de este
pequeño país el canal es una arteria
vital hay trabajo por hacer con 80
kilómetros el canal conecta y permite el
paso de barcos entre el océano atlántico
y el océano pacifico y desde su
inauguración en 1914 lo han cruzado más
de 700 mil buques convirtiéndose así en
uno de los enclaves más importantes del
comercio mundial cada año le reporta a
gobierno panameño más de mil millones de
euros en ingresos y tras ocho años de
intensas obras en casi uno de los varios
proyectos
de la ingeniería moderna y 5000 millones
de euros de inversión el próximo 26 de
junio se inaugurará la ampliación del
canal que tiene como objetivo duplicar
su capacidad y permitir el paso de los
barcos conocidos como post-panamax
barcos de mayor dimensión que irán a
transportar más de 13 mil contenedores
cada uno junto al canal el otro elemento
característico de panamá es que es uno
de los pocos países del mundo que no
tiene banco central así como lo
escucháis en panamá tanto los tipos de
interés como los niveles de vídeo y
crédito de la economía se determinan por
la libre interacción entre oferentes y
demandantes de capital quienes además
tienen pleno acceso a los mercados
internacionales sin ningún tipo de
restricción además como en panamá no hay
un banco emisor de moneda en la economía
de facto sea dolarizado con lo cual ni
ciudadanos ni empresas están sujetos al
riesgo cambiario el riesgo de los tipos
de cambio de divisas hay quien puede
pensar que carecer del auto central
puede ser un origen de muchos problemas
o inestabilidad espero panamá hasta
luego todo lo contrario el hecho de
carecer de este organismo de
planificación le ha supuesto convertirse
en una de las macro economías más
estables de todo el mundo
es el único país de latinoamérica que
jamás ha conocido colapso financiero
alguno la última crisis financiera la de
2008 la pasó por un crecimiento
económico envidiable y sin que ninguno
de sus bancos tuviesen el mismo problema
y hoy pugna por ser la capital
financiera latinoamérica en panamá
operan más de 90 bancos más del doble
que en méxico y casi el triple de los
que operan en toda españa sabéis cómo
llevan a irse los pobres
las torres de la cocaína y a nuestros 85
bancos las lavanderías
pero claro no podemos hablar de panamá
ni de su sistema fiscal sin mencionar su
supuesta condición como paraíso fiscal
su reputación como tal data allá desde
hace más de 100 años y la estándar
lobilla registraba sus buques en este
país para permitirle al magnate john
rockefeller reducir su carga tributaria
a los eeuu aunque sin duda la explosión
como supuesto paraíso fiscal llegó una
década de los 80 en los tiempos
difíciles quizá en la época de noriega
la justicia de los violentos cuando de
la mano de su dictador manuel antonio
noriega a panamá se convirtió en el
refugio del dinero del narcotráfico
particularmente del dinero del cártel de
medellín quien liberado por pablo
escobar conseguía ganar cada año más de
4 mil millones de euros pero esta
historia acabó en diciembre de 1989
cuando estados unidos invadió panamá y
condenó a noriega a pasar el resto de
sus días en cárceles y centros
penitenciarios de eeuu francia y panamá
una estrella que falta en nuestra
bandera señor
me parece que dios nos
pero por qué el dinero escoge este país
porque el dinero acude a panamá
fundamentalmente porque este país tiene
normativas que tratan de salvaguardar el
secreto bancario y la confidencialidad
las transacciones y porque es uno de los
pocos países donde se pueden constituir
sociedades con la emisión de acciones al
portador esto es que garantizan el
anonimato de sus propietarios todo ello
junto a las posibilidades su sistema
bancario hacen de este país un lugar
ideal para quienes en el mejor de los
casos tratan de vivir de regímenes
fiscales opresores y en el plano de
ellos quienes tratan de esconder el
dinero de actividades ilícitas
bienvenido a panamá
casablanca sin héroes
pero a pesar de ser un enclave logístico
y financiero destacado panamá no es un
país rico es verdad que desde 1990 ha
crecido mucho más de un 6% cada año pero
también es cierto que la pobreza sigue
siendo una lacra que afecta a más del
20% la población y además del 10% en el
caso de la pobreza extrema pero por qué
ocurre todo esto principalmente por tres
motivos el primero de ellos la economía
de panamá no es precisamente libre
es verdad que hay bajos impuestos pero
también mucha burocracia y además
existen controles de precios los costes
de contratación o laborales son muy
altos el gasto público también es
elevado y las políticas de subsidios y
proteccionismo suelen ser más que
habituales hay una horrible red de
blanqueo
de drogas y corrupción el gobierno de
panamá se puede decir es un gobierno pro
amiguetes más que un gobierno pro
mercado así no es extraño que el índice
de libertad económica ocupe el puesto 66
y en el índice doing bussiness del
puesto 69
todos conocemos lo relacionado otros
siguientes están con el nivel de
riquezas de un país
en segundo lugar en panamá hay una
oligarquía que controla tanto el poder
político como el poder económico
buen ejemplo de todo esto es el de ramón
josé k fundador del conocidísimo bufete
monsac fonseca que hasta hace unas pocas
semanas además era ministro consejero de
gobierno y presidente del primer partido
político del país y esto no es una
excepción es un hecho habitual y en
tercer lugar la corrupción según el
índice transparencia internacional
depreciación de la corrupción panamá
ocupa el puesto 71 y además tiene un
problema con la politización de la
justicia es verdad que no todo es malo y
en los últimos tiempos se han logrado
muchos avances tal vez el más destacado
de todos ellos sea la declaración de la
ciudad de color como zona libre tratando
de emular el éxito que en el pasado
iniciativas similares tuvieron en hong
kong o macao vamos a ver cómo evoluciona
este país desde luego si apuestan por la
competitividad el potencial de panamá le
puede llevar a convertirse que la
singapore de latinoamérica